what's this i don't know it's a
different look uh yeah i got us a new
table and new chairs
just you know i listen to you guys when
you complain about stuff these are
chairs that don't slide
they don't they don't slide they do move
up and down if you want to like come up
[Laughter]
see when you actually when you slide
they kind of ride up they ride your
undies up in your butt
[Laughter]
well charlie can slide on anyone put
some sticky tape i did i did grease my
gloves
yes is this the thing now yeah different
things well you know what we can do
either thing i like the table i like
this okay yeah yeah you can kind of lean
set you can lean into it i've also got
your headphones there that's for when we
watch the episode we can change
if we want yeah we can go back to the
other chairs we still have them
people don't like change ladies and
gentlemen this is the part of the
podcast where megan has to explain
things three different times one because
charlie was singing uh while she was
explaining the first time secondly
between the two of us right now and then
glenn's gonna walk in she's gonna
explain it again but only if glenn asks
if glenn doesn't ask megan doesn't
necessarily have to offer the
information we'll find out
what a thing i don't listen
i'm glad you guys like the table i like
it yeah that's a beautiful tip it's
heavy let's get this in here pinocchio
um
three strong men
and a dolly yeah that's right
that's right i just paid some men you
can just pay men you can just perform
these
with
payments
you can always pay a man to lift
you guys will always be useful for that
as long as you can listen
you can't pay me to lift [ __ ]
good morning and
here
he is
mr america
so today i'd like to start
because i'm coming in hot today with
some structure for this podcast [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] okay we did say the structure we
would just do a bunch of episodes and
then the structure would just sort of
emerge emerged yeah but i thought it was
going to be
more organic more organic yeah okay
something's gonna be forced upon us
could we get some structure to how we
find structure
yeah um i was waiting for it to just
emerge but then i thought maybe after 46
episodes i should maybe forcefully
emerge it yeah but you guys can resist
it then and
not do it
if you don't like the structure
we could know about it yeah
you mean this will be the structure
moving forward could be
i'm just going to pitch some structure
to the podcast we have regular little
segments
but the first one is just coming in hot
which is just what you guys do naturally
anyway which is
just the first segment of the show would
be who's coming in hot we like it hot
hot uh that's the buster poindexter song
you know busted point next to he was a
campfire store
[Laughter]
shoot scenes with him and he'd always
say so the singer the new york dolphins
he sure was and he would start every
take with like let's shoot this
[ __ ]
and i was like that's like that's good i
like that i'm not gonna use it but um
i'm not gonna use it or ever do it
yeah yeah
well i like that meg i'm uh
i'm coming in hot with a couple of
things today so yeah what are you
talking about i'm i'm yeah i'm feeling
quite content and sort of well i don't
want to derail ma meg's attempted
structure right now so i could we could
we could talk about what i'm hot about
or we could just go no that's part of
the structure
it's it's who's coming in the hottest
guy you know we start with a high i saw
another event i think it's because of
the heat
uh in los angeles and really all over
the world and also because
i think people are still coming out of
the pandemic and don't know how to act
around other human beings so everybody's
acting like an animal yeah
i saw another event um i was not
involved of um
although i thought i might have to be of
we're gonna step in yeah the hero
complex yeah
[Laughter]
people could spell that if that was your
last name oh you could change your name
to rob justice which would be a much
better name than rob macklin like that
rob justice i like that if you go out
and ask 10 people if they could spell
justice i'll bet you 50 can get it right
oh god you think that's it walk around
bud
have you been walking around recently no
no i don't leave
and i came outside of myself and said
and i was like looking at it and i was
like okay were you driving
jump in it was we were we were stopped i
wasn't
gonna get out and jumped it right what
happened wow it was insane
i'm driving along uh sunset boulevard
and um i see this woman who's like right
she's a little ahead of me she's in the
right-hand lane okay
i see her roll down her window and she
very clearly takes her hand and has it's
like full of detritus i don't know
exactly what it is
she just thank you for using she just
throws it out the window right for those
who don't know what detroit is it is a
very good word yeah but it's it's it's a
fantastic track
it's like it's like knick-knack trash
you know what i mean it's it's less so
like trash you think of like banana
peels and detritus is more like the
loose stuff that's in like the the like
cup holder in your door i don't know
what the screw goes yeah yeah yeah
well that's what it looks like
willy-nilly it happens so it happened so
fast it wasn't the stuff that's not big
enough for a thrift store
yeah like you know like i like all right
so usually i just need to try something
donut but when you see somebody like
flick a cigarette out of their car
window which of course in fire season is
always dangerous and disgusting anyway
but at least you go i guess i understand
nobody wants to have a cigarette butt in
their car uh but this woman
this woman just
to charlie's point it looked like she
just went down the side like that little
side pocket was just like like you know
what it's like a i don't like this
because i'm sick of this
[ __ ] i need a place for my water it
looked like there was like bits of
plastic it was just a bunch that's why i
used the word to try to say it just
looked like a bunch she didn't look
first to make sure you weren't around
before she threw this out her coffee
was around
she'd think
that's right well that's why that's why
you need to start to garner a reputation
throughout the city because then people
will be aware that if they throw
detritus out the window rob justice
might be yeah you get a bumper sticker
say i stopped for detritus
yeah that's right and and you know it's
like it's like the beginning of the the
michael keaton batman the first uh tim
burton batman you know he's like tell
your friends about it
because he's like holding the guy
tell your friends about it doesn't he
say that anyway okay sorry the picture
what kind of a car we talked could have
been a crime too it could be like
evidence she's trying to get rid of no
it was it was a nice it was a nice car
and i spotted this it was a white bmw so
if any so if there's a lady driving out
on sunset before on a white bmw what
year are we taught like it's a new one
it was a night it was a nice car it was
a nice okay okay and of course whenever
i see people throwing things out the
window i'm always fascinated oh yeah i i
actually don't think this is why i ask
anger it's more fascination yeah i don't
get it i recognize like that woman lives
ostensibly in the city i mean she she
most likely lives in the neighborhood
that she just threw her [ __ ] yeah like
if it's a crappy car you already don't
like it but at least you think man maybe
their life circumstances are so bad they
just can't take it anymore and yeah
they're just like the world [ __ ] me so
[ __ ] the world and and and i have
compassion it's still i don't uh
you can't excuse the behavior but you
have compassion for that you say people
just go i don't give a [ __ ] oh i think i
think asked me over and over and over
again i think a key
element to rob justice is compassion i
think i think without compassion rob
justice is just rob fury
fury is a different rob fury's a
different vengeance no no
so
you're mad at this elite elitist minus
chucker no fascinated no no i i don't
even have a i don't even have a split
second to be upset oh because what
happens is what i hear
is
like someone like [ __ ] slams on the
brakes and then i look like out of the
corner of my eye and the mirror i see a
jeep that's behind her that like swerves
right and and then honks on his horn
and then i look back and this guy's in a
dead stop and then there's cars behind
him and i thought i heard like did
somebody like slam into the back of him
but i don't think that that's what
happened because then we're continuing
on and then i realized like if
i i pieced it together that whatever she
threw out he like swerved to miss
because he didn't want to get this in
your
yeah like it's all happening very fast
but she speeds up now
she's ahead of me like bro
tannish brown
i don't know i'm just trying to get a
full picture here at all i was just
thinking like it was a white jeep and
then you're like that detritus is going
to really show on my car if it hits it
you know but it's already a brown jeep
so i'd move to get out of the way so a
jeep
right through to try this it's like
exactly that's what's the point of
having a jeep the fact that he swerved
at all is is absurd i need to have a
conversation with him about why well my
guess is based on how quickly it
happened he might just not know what was
happening there was just like a bunch of
talking about a wrangler like top
rank wrangler
and i i i learned very quickly that the
top was down the windows were everything
okay so that detritus could be getting
in and hitting this guy talking airborne
to try to stop
then i then
we
right what was the height this was
thrown out was it a low chuck or was it
tall it was even weirder
and this leads me to believe that maybe
there was food involved because she
threw it out and then as she as i was
watching this like i can't believe that
that just happened i watched her come in
and she was and she rolled up the win
the window was going up
on one side she made it maybe it was on
her right side that she could put the
window up and i watched her do like this
like she was wiping her hands off like
like get that out of my car greasy
french fries or like a peanut and this
wrangler guy could have an allergy so
this is a life and death situation right
he's he's swerving to me so peanut hits
him in the yeah yeah he's fighting for
his life yeah i'm assuming it's a he i
don't know why oh yeah
it's most definitely a he so then the we
we wind up stopping in traffic and then
this car
just peels out the jeep peels because
now he's at a dead stop he peels towards
us and i'm like oh man this is gonna but
there's a part of me that's thinking oh
great i don't i don't have to do this
woman's about to get some justice but
i don't know what he's going to do
so he sort of we are all rob justice
type situation no well this one you know
what i mean like guy fury yeah oh this
is a guy
this is guy fury and he i look over he's
got a shaved head and i'm like okay
already someone with a [ __ ] he's
consciously making
a choice to shave his head it could be
that he's an actor playing a part it
could be that he has cancer
it could be that he's just going bald or
it could be that this is a choice he he
wants to look a certain way right he
could see harrah's detritus and just
feel like he's got to get all the time
yeah yeah yeah so yeah yeah
and he gets really up close to her and
just lays on the horn now i'm next to
her
and she's just like
dead like just hands on the 11 and two
just staring forward can i guess yeah
50s yeah i'm picturing 50s 60s yeah
early early 50s i feel like a person in
their 20s
in this day and age for the most part
is like
you can't do that but it's like once you
hit a certain age i feel like you know
you're either the type of person who has
bettered themselves or you're the type
of person who's like
this is my world yeah or you suffered a
lifetime of petty miseries and you just
you know well but the petty miseries are
at a certain point are your fault if
you're driving around like a bmw and
you're doing you're going to say you've
got a bmw man
not to say that should be good yeah not
to suggest that she doesn't have her
fair amount of pain however it's pre
it's privileged pain yeah it's right
right which is a different kind of pain
which still do
yes meaning there's a stolen man a
stolen car we don't know it's really
hard
well she was going somewhere at what 8
30 in the morning she was coming from
the west side sure there's only so many
places you can you're either living in
malibu or the pacific palisades or
brentwood or santa monica you're doing
okay now does that
mean that you don't you're not unhappy
that you don't have pain in your life no
of course not but there's no excuse for
the throwing the trash out the window so
what okay
you're next to her i'm next and then the
jeep is behind her behind her and he's
just like laying on the horn right and
then and he's like yelling at her but
she's pretending not to notice and i'm
like okay like see let's get out the
popcorn because now i want to see what's
happening
then i love the idea of pretending not
to notice oh what what else you do in
that situation because god the guy is
she's stuck in traffic she the guy could
get out of the car that's right
so then the the the light goes green and
we pull up and i see he's trying to get
behind me or next to me just to get next
to her yeah so uh and this is now we're
in stop dead traffic it's on sunset at
rush hour so eventually we come to
another red and he gets right up next to
her and he like pulls up next to her
and he honks on a horn honks on the horn
and he's like roll down your window roll
down your window she's not rolling down
her window he spits
onto her car
spits onto the car and now i'm like oh
[ __ ] how did he launch his spit that far
like was he yeah so over the passenger
seat on to oh did he go to the passenger
seat remember that jeep was wide open so
i don't know
if he went over the roll bar or through
the roll i just saw him make a very
clear spitting motion so this guy's a
good spitter
spit is like liquid detritus that's
right liquid to try to the detritus of
the body yeah and if you've got your top
if
you're completely topless car wise yeah
you know you can you can launch it like
a mortar yeah i don't i'm not sure if
the expectorate actually hit the window
or not
i'm not sure if it actually if it
actually made contact but it who knows
he's already pretty aerodynamic on
account of the shaved head so like it's
just like a cannon here yeah he's ready
maybe his hair blew off because he was
driving around in the cheeks
maybe he has cancer and he was on his
way to get his chemotherapy and he had
mucus in his lungs
who knows and he needed to he needed to
work that out right these are all the
things that rob justice is weighing up
in his head absolutely
traffic sucks as it is and it's pretty
interesting that you like something
interesting but i'm also thinking
uh i'm also thinking at this point now
has
has the sca have the scales of justice
flipped
at what point do you need to engage what
you're wondering which when do i get
together yeah what does this what does
this become about now i'm getting gel
now i feel jealous i'm like why do i why
do i only get to watch this why can't i
be a part of it yeah sure right so how
can i insert myself into this to raise
it from an eight to like an eleven yeah
yeah yeah like let's just let's
where's the showmanship here where's the
opportunity to really escalate this yeah
dangerous situation right so um so that
you can feel something so that i can
feel as though i'm important right so i
can make this about me and not his spit
or her to try this
do you still have the metal baseball
bats in the back of your car no
there was no there was a thought
there was a thought
i love the devil how do you bash that's
the question it's like i know i should
pass someone with this guy like
rob justice
gets the jeep in there are no winners in
this only losers that's right yeah so
you might as well bash a couple loser
nerds yeah
trash thrown straight and spit chucking
so i'm not sure if this guy's gonna get
out of his car like she's terrified now
and
now i'm thinking well
yes she deserves to be
admonished and but not certainly not
like physically harmed in any way but i
don't know that he hit now i'm noticing
he's got a seat belt on so he's he's
safe which is good but i'm thinking once
that seat belt comes off he's going to
get out of that car and we're just
stopped in dead traffic and i'm just
watching watching watching and then
luckily the light turns green
and she just makes a right turn and just
gets off the street and i'm thinking
he's either going to follow her or he's
going to keep going down sunset and he
kept going down sunset screaming at
himself the entire way
and then he like you know when you're
like upset and you he just wanted to
drive fast he like found a turn lane in
the middle of the road and just like
zoomed down sunset
for no particular reason other than his
rage now if he had turned after her
would you have
you had to go pursued i definitely would
have because he he looked like he was
going to kill her
well this this lady you know
threw her detritus on the wrong on the
wrong jeep ring
and uh and and perhaps
perhaps we'll think twice i know that's
the [ __ ] up thing about human beings
is that you want to believe that
that people wouldn't do that in the
first place right but she did it and now
the next time she
goes down to that side pocket and
picks up a bag of
vaseline and and
dog hair and pretzels
she won't throw it out because she'll go
you know what there might be some
psychopath behind me who might spit on
my isn't that interesting i mean that's
that's a uh
you know as you as we struggle with the
you know struggle with how to discipline
our our children when they do something
wrong you know in an ideal world you
want that woman to think i'm not gonna
throw this detritus out the window
because it's the wrong thing to do it's
bad for the environment i should just
wait find a trash can or maybe even
recycle some of these components
uh and uh you know you want that to be
her reason not like the fear of like
some psycho and a jeep wrangler beating
her ass but sometimes
well natural consequences are a real
thing that's that's the thing with like
parenting right you don't want to you
don't want to give punishment out you
want to but you do want to instill
natural consequences for behavior
sometimes there aren't any i know but is
that is in this circumstance the natural
consequence that somebody either like a
cop
might see you and write you a ticket
which we all know is never going to
happen or someone might come and bash
you up i mean i i don't know
who knows we can't we can't
you you're getting into perception and
reality here as far as we know these two
are lovers right
this is some sick dance that they do you
know it's like it's like i drive this is
this is yeah
she goes she takes a ride he goes
straight they meet around the corner at
the back of their apartment and they
have crazy sex you know they're like
that was great the whole scene he was
speeding off to do an end around to the
apartment that they were going to go
meet at that's right this is like their
weird sick dance man that is hot yeah
because it's the only way that they can
attempt to reproduce
yeah and this is what they just are
desperate to have a child nothing's
working and they're like maybe if we
maybe if i'm furious enough maybe if
you're
you know right
maybe if you seem privileged enough and
i'm and i seem sort of low class and yes
yes yeah that's hot
that's pretty hot it's pretty hot anyway
speaking of revenge this episode yeah oh
god there you go are we talking about an
episode today rob that was a good story
thanks for bringing it oh yeah i think i
came in hot coming in hot with that um
this leads right into my next possible
structure idea which is that people keep
asking for us to do little like recaps
of what the episode is about um at the
start so we know which one we're talking
about so yeah um this segment is called
that is what happened and it's just
where i give like a short thing about
like uh what episode we're about to
watch season four episode eight paddy's
pub the worst bar in philadelphia it
aired on october 16 2008
written by scott martyr and rob rozelle
and david hornsby directed by matt
shakman in this episode a newspaper
reporter gives paddy's pub a terrible
review so the gang kidnaps him in order
to smooth things over
as one does that is what happened that
is what happened what is what is what
happened yes i have not seen this
episode in ages
so no recollection
okay i know he gets tied to a chair
yeah i remember very little you know
what it's not such a big deal with short
hair but headphones on and off once the
hair is longer
well it's either on or it's off i don't
know we're going to be able to
i don't know if this is sustainable once
my hair once your hair grows out what if
you wear them what if yeah what if you
wear or put them together yeah then you
do that or you go you go like this
[Laughter]
protect the hair at all costs yeah
exactly um okay here we go
oh it's just four 442
oh it's incredible
yeah it's thin sure but
wait actually can we pause i wonder if
we did i wonder if we did 442 because
that's
that's the time
that i was born on my birth certificate
i wonder if
that had something i mean that can't be
a coincidence right
that's literally when i was born
was that the same day of the week no no
i'm just saying it was it was at 4 42 no
whatever
i was actually born at 4 20. on my uh on
my birth certificate [ __ ]
that's cool man
that's [ __ ] cool yeah
oh it's just so doggone thin oh it's
incredibly thin yeah it's thin sure but
i gotta say i don't care for it
charlie the thinner the tv the better
the tv that's just straight up fast guys
guys guys check it out all right
already we're discussing the thinness of
tvs as if it's kind of a like a
a new thing
it was a new thing it was a new thing
was this a direct tv ad that you guys
placed in because it says
direct tv on the sure
i don't know
very prominently i didn't know if it was
like a tie-in or something
that may have been around the time that
fox bought directv
you think they said
mr murdock bought a uh bought direct tv
and i might have snuck that in i don't
know
yeah for the uh for the listener and uh
creep um
whenever you see a product
on our show
uh it's either because we got away with
it
or
we're not getting paid but the network
is getting paid so
just so we're clear
we're not getting paid
by directv no no we are getting paid by
the network and studio and they
the more money the show makes the more
money they're willing to pay us well
that's not even true it's the more money
that we are willing to negotiate for and
threaten to quit
oh i don't know a thousand yeah
all right okay
guys guys guys check it out we got a
review in the paper read it write it
rate it green paper
the first thing i noticed about paddy's
pub is its charm all right it's a good
question
it has none it has none oh are you
serious there was an ominous feeling
that you could get stabbed at any moment
that's good right how is that good
that's the exact type of atmosphere i've
been trying to cultivate but while
danger may linger i'm the level-headed
bouncer that keeps violence in check
like swayze and roadhouse what cooler we
added
yeah yeah yeah we had a debate about
whether or not to add that swoosh uh
that seems like something glenn would
want oh there's this that i would want
there's a swim yeah i think we were all
pretty much on the same page
i think we all kind of agreed it's a
little over the top but it made us all
laugh is violence in check like swayze
and roadhouse oh it's literally yeah or
did you think that my my movement
actually made that focus i think we
debated more the volume of it we're like
it's fine to have a thing in there but
how long right how loud
uh patrick swayze and roadhouse yes
r.i.p patrick swayze all right
two-year-olds i've never seen roadhouse
is that like a favorite movie have you
ever
yeah
that's true i need to remedy that in
studio i think a in-studio viewing of
roadhouse would be absolutely phenomenal
100 i would be all in on that man i love
that movie and i've seen it in a long
time i have not seen this in
so good yeah
yeah it comes back again in this episode
i just remember there being doesn't it
like there's like a band whenever the
band plays they're like behind a cage
yeah are they like behind the camera
well because they play the guy's blind
right yeah yeah jeff healy that's a real
bad jeffy oh right jeffy yeah right how
do i talk to an angel and does he play
behind a cage usually
not in real life
i just don't think it's right times have
changed yeah you know think about
thinking i mean like usually you can
hock up a beer bottle on stage if you
don't like it but if you're blind and
they can dodge it yeah you can't dodge
it that's right so you gotta have the
cage jeff i i think jeff jeff has passed
as well did jeff pass
i think so all right well r.i.p jeff i
want to pee jeff
in check there have been many stabbings
here yeah i feel unsafe here every
single day very often well stabbings
have been down though
i ordered a glass of wine not only did
the surly white trash waitress refuse to
make it but she proceeded to call me a
word that i cannot print in this paper
surly i was forced to listen to the
three classless boars who call
themselves the owners get drunk and yell
over each other okay wait well this is
just us commenting on the show
it's basically us
us commenting on all the criticisms of
the show yeah it may have been what we
took we took a review yeah and just
changed
i think i think the the the sentiment we
knew the sentiment existed out there in
the world i don't know how because we
didn't have social media at the time so
we weren't looking at comments and stuff
but there were comments on like on imdb
you could go to our imdb page remember
and you could went wrong i mean no it is
yeah often that
i'm totally yelling over each other it's
just a matter of whether it's very
entertaining yeah that's my that's my
style i think it's very charming
[Music]
okay this one goes out to you fantasy
football fans but not just any of you
i'm talking to the nerds you know who
you are you who has this podcast on in
the background as you sift through 30
tabs of research for your last minute
draft don't panic and reach on a qb
again this year the first sunday of the
nfl season is here and draftkings
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl is giving new
customers a can't-miss offer to
celebrate the return of football right
now new customers can bet just five
dollars and get
in free bets instantly basically you can
use your money to buy more money buying
money these days that's great download
the draftking sports book app now and
use promo code always to get two hundred
dollars in free bets
instantly when you place a five dollar
bet on any football game that's code
always only a draftking sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nfl that's always a l w a y s minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply
see show notes
for details
today we are brought to you by our
friends at manscape the leader in below
the waist grooming we all know that
being shaved and smooth is vital to peak
confidence there's a certain confidence
that comes with being properly groomed
down in your netherlands it's an aura
it's a it's a vibe
it's science bge big groomed energy so
how does one acquire bge we put our top
minds on the case and uh so far we've
only found one way to retain a constant
state of bge
the manscape platinum package
4.0 it's a one-stop shop for men who
deserve it all they've designed this
package to redesign your package so you
walk around like you're pete davidson so
go ahead and join the four million men
worldwide who trust manscaped get 20 off
and free shipping with the code sunny
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com use the code
sunny unlock your big groomed energy
with manscaped and remember
when you trim the hedges
the tree stands taller
[Music]
fisher stevens
hi are you mr lyle corman yes can i help
you oh nice to meet you yeah we're here
from paddy's class and we have come down
together okay hold on so
we talked about matt a little bit but uh
this is directed by matt shachman matt
chachman is one of the biggest directors
in hollywood right now i know that's
crazy yes but he
he signed on to do fantastic four he
might be directing the fantastic four
movie but i think he may have even
dropped out he did of that to do a
bigger movie no no he dropped out of
star trek
oh he was signed on to do star trek and
he had to drop out because it's it
conflicted with fantastic four almost
said fabulous for
we should potentially do a movie called
the feather the fabulous fabulous four
by the way fisher stevens uh
is not only a great actor who's been
around a long time but a great producer
as well uh producing many
amazing movies doc's features um
succession
he's on success he's great on succession
and i remember thinking it was like a
big deal that he wanted to do the show
like did we
he certainly didn't audition for it we
must have just reached out like no i
think wendy came to us and said fisher
had come in for something else and that
he mentioned that he was a fan of sunny
oh is that what it was yeah yeah and we
liked and we liked him
oh my god
it's great yeah yeah yeah
same you know what buddy we will jam
your [ __ ] up with so many lawyers
you won't know what to do with yourself
i'll have you know we have a team of
lawyers on retainer just to deal with
people like you
really yeah well check this out
you're all out of time [ __ ] boom
you just got phased this just in poo poo
pants people don't read newspapers
anymore
pause there you go okay poo poo pants
this is
this is the second time
that we've talked on this podcast or
scene um someone deal with the situation
by spitting yes yeah we're just dealing
with animals
we're at people are animals it is uh one
of the ultimate signs of disrespect
isn't it to spit in someone's food or
their coffee or in their face or on
their bmw yep
and by the way kind of crazy to think
that people aren't animals
yeah right because they are we're all
right that's true we're fighting it all
the time right we're when we don't spit
we're containing it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
we should be lauded for not spitting
more often in fact very few animals spit
um camels you know
yeah
nasty stuff just [ __ ] spitting
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] camels and another thing
about camels
i don't want to start on the campbells
you know
how to get the water in that hump you
know what i mean all right let's get all
that milk in there
[Laughter]
it's like less than 20 seconds from you
saying we're not white trash to breaking
his clocks spitting in his coffee cups
hey you guys want to see something
what
i did something
you know reservoir dogs yeah
i don't really know what happened okay
first i was angry then i was drinking
next thing i know i'm following this guy
home and forcing him into the trunk of
his own car this is bad really don't
panic don't panic
we're really sorry about this mr corman
we're going to go all right okay it's
not a kidnapping
damn it
all right well you just so
i'm sure people noticed this before but
that curb is just so absurdly high
it's a wonder they had that they haven't
somebody hasn't sued the city over that
uh people sued the city over way dumber
[ __ ]
than that which is actually very
dangerous yeah yeah you see us like
danny i mean we need to get him like a
step stool to get up on that [ __ ]
thing yeah i know you chopper him in and
out of the yeah
[Laughter]
it's the carrying him like a wrecking
ball or is it a straight low
it's a good question because yeah i
think maybe it's a combo of both
it's a very strange they figure it out
on most streets though you know what i
mean they figured out how to not have
the curb be too high i mean that's
ridiculous i've never seen that anything
like that anywhere else other than here
yeah yeah well that's part of the charm
the uniqueness of this isn't the show
yeah
okay i think we're all on the same page
this is not a kidnapping no no okay all
right what we do need to keep him here
for a couple of hours so he doesn't do
anything wrong
go to the police that's being said let's
take a few precautions here we need to
cover our tracks you know why don't we
shoot over to corman's place and make
sure that charlie left without a trace
well i'll tell you mr fancy pants writer
ma'am
i was thinking maybe you could get the
new review you know and this is just
maybe add a few less lies
how can i write a new review if i am
taped to a chair come on man see he's
twisting everything i said around he's
making me look like an actress look look
nobody has to write anything against
their will okay thank you
i have to go to the bathroom huh i have
to pee
okay sidebar
i don't really remember any of this
yeah like yeah little pieces but yeah i
remember uh friends of corman which is
about to come up right here
yeah oh when those neighbors yeah i
don't remember that
friends of corman yeah right right right
right yeah that was funny that did not
sound like cormac
who are you people
friends with gorman yeah yeah mr corman
lives across the hall
wow does he dizzy
[Music]
where is he this is remember that at all
so you guys got the wrong apartment yeah
got the wrong apartment another roommate
now there's two now there's two kids in
that part that's right yeah well we
don't know that yet but yeah yeah
it's called uh could see the writing
escalation yes
classic escalation
now back to the cooler conversation that
we were having earlier i feel like in
your article you missed an opportunity
to mention my bouncing abilities okay
now it's really more about smarts than
anything else for example if there was
an altercation in this bathroom i would
blast in looking to neutralize yeah now
i would check out my environment and i
would look to see if there's anything
that i could use to my advantage
like this pool cue here we go
so earlier in the show we have
we put in the sound effect of my hand
whipping through and that just happened
naturally and then here i'm adding it
you're doing it i'm doing it yeah yeah
always wait a minute hold on a second is
that what
i don't think i ever knew that i always
thought you were going
because you were doing the the you were
doing like breaths
you were making the sound the sound that
the dude
i'm learning that right now
i always thought that was like it was
like a like it was some kind of a
breathing technique thing no no i was
doing the sound effects for the holy
[ __ ]
did you know that am i an idiot no i
probably thought of it as like just like
a
yeah like a breathing thing
that's so interesting wow i can't that's
hey listen
we're learning you know it's one of the
beautiful things you picture dogs to
poop yeah i learned that oh by the way i
did that this morning for the first time
in a very long time i i did that this
morning and you know what to answer your
earlier question about what kind of dog
it was it was like a i'd say around a 30
pound dog it was white
for some reason it was definitely you
know in that position
uh it's just just a mutt you know what i
mean but it was white
good like a white dog yeah good yeah
because the juxtaposition against the
brown poop really helps you see it i
think that's right that's why yeah does
this dog have a name
no the dog doesn't have a name as far as
i know i mean i'm sure he does but is he
in a field is it a she he or what are we
talking about it's not that specific of
a conjuring okay okay it's just it's not
that specific it's just a medium-sized
white dog that's right yes and he's sort
of floating in space in my mind
sure
well you know i i think it was like one
of those things where like it i i just
remembered our conversation about it
so then i i just pictured it but i i
don't know that i really needed it i
just it just kind of happened oh god
yeah yeah inspired in there yeah
and normally that wouldn't happen unless
i wanted it to right because i could
fire right in your chest because i got
the skills to do that dude there's like
no tape anywhere all i can scrounge up
is a bin banana
no that's too small oh i could wear it
though
i should wear it i know but i found it
so i sort of feel like no i appreciate
you looking for me and finding it for me
and doing the charlie well it's
immediately becoming about who gets to
wear it that's not even why you brought
it in that's very our show
yeah i brought it in tie his hands up
but now we want who wants to wear it to
look cool yeah now that you know that
wearing it is an option
[Laughter]
no i'm throwing no it's wrong
i've got to be kidding me just please
get me out of this bathroom before i
vomit it is absolutely disgusting
well excuse me mr man so i didn't get
again the cat well kathy bates and uh
very hard cleaning it
in fact it's so clean i would say you
could eat out of these urinals you
absolutely cannot eat out
oh really what's this charlie don't try
oh my gosh
wait i remember what what that was that
he was eating rice cake nope no no
do you remember
yes jicama yeah
yeah
because it had that it had the the
texture of quality and the crunch nice
it was sitting in there
but that's a fake urinal nobody has ever
peed in that we don't know that for sure
we don't know that we don't know where
it was sourced yeah
yeah that might it looks like a public
poor park it probably came from a public
park service
one of us is gonna have to help his whoa
dude i'm not touching his dick well
charlie you're the one that used all the
tape well i was comfortable with letting
him piss in his back all right fine then
compromise
we'll both do it that way it's equally
weird for both of us please no oh no
no no
he's creating this
everyone's trumpized
did he get a little bit hard on us can
we not talk about it i just felt like he
got a little bit it was very weird
why did it move we had a problem
oh
man what happened dude there was a
slight mix-up with the apartments this
is corman's neighbor mayhar what
happened to doing this without a trace
well it's a long story but the punchline
is that he started asking questions the
punchline
well you asked a lot of questions well
let's not have him ask more questions
okay let's just keep him in the trunk
for now can't kidnap more people to
cover up the original kidnapping it's a
classic mistake oh i'm sorry i didn't
know there was a handbook on kidnapping
jesus
we got to get him inside probably very
hot in there there's another bit of an
issue which is that i locked the keys in
the trunk just now what yeah are you
kidding me oh my god well i didn't want
to bring that up god damn it charlie
it's what we're gonna do you guys deal
with the situation out here okay let's
go talk to corman he's writing that new
review okay cause i don't want to see
that man right now we don't want to deal
with him anymore what happened
something happened none of your business
yeah
amongst the guys
please guys please
you have to hike up your pants watch
this to get out of this curve you have
to hike up your jeans because you can't
get a stretch i can't get enough yeah
the jeans didn't have as much stretch
back then you gave them a little tug
yeah they weren't they made them i also
had to angle my knee inward
in order to get up there yeah because
you got to stretch your hips out stop
god you guys remember jeans with no
stretch [ __ ] that
they look they look pretty loose buddy
damn it dude i feel like they should be
oh yeah people break into cars all the
time you know a piece of me wants to
chop this whole guy in the trunk thing
up to a loss right now no we can't do
that bro we got to get him out of the
car oh then why don't you just let me
take the hammer and smash the window
we'll just pop the trunk charlie if we
were going to smash the window i would
simply do it with a roundhouse kick oh
come on dude i do break this window with
a roundhouse kick let's get serious here
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know what there is a slope in the
ground and i didn't i wasn't you just i
wasn't calibrating that great mirror oh
man
take one karate class if you're so into
karate you know
that is a real i mean that's nice you
saying that almost makes me feel like
maybe we did
we did have earlier references to it i
mean
i don't know or maybe it's just you're
just referencing the number of times
he's insisting on it i think it's come
up before him with
i mean he did but the first time he ever
did that was in the dancing right was
that
in the dancing episode and he doesn't
talk about
being a karate master or anything that's
true i don't know super into it in this
episode so maybe did you guys have like
a bible that you wrote about your
characters and stuff or anything
of course extensive yeah no no no very
tolkien-esque you know sort of like a
whole family tree like the whole yeah
yeah about mac being gay but it wouldn't
come out
that much later oh absolutely
yeah i mean listen we're the after we
finish with it's always sunny in
philadelphia we're going to do a game of
thrones thing go back go back to like
there's a pretty freaking
pre-prequel sure yeah that's a good idea
hey man do you see any hypodermic
needles laying around what the hell is
that mayhar's cat diabetic now a
diabetic cat is in play jesus we can't
catch a break i know tell me about you
now
oh jesus christ charlie you broke the
window dude the guy had to take a dump
what was that supposed to do wait he's
all tied up how did you let's not talk
about how it happened okay it just
happened give him his cat dude your
cat's freaking out not my cat no oh my
god
what the hell are you doing dude what's
mayor doing here what are you doing with
my cat your cat
jesus christ where is going mr corman
why are they doing this
in the office jesus christ
another cat actor how is it to work with
cats this is the second one i think
after age it's kind of a pain to work
with like that's a little tough yeah
dogs like
obeys rules better
cats they do it better but let's be
let's be honest
i've met people who have trained their
dogs
just to be around how they want them to
behave around the house a thousand times
better than any animal trainer we have
ever
worked with who can't ever get the dog
to do
anything
it's astounding to me
it's astounding to me how little
the people who are hired to
train dogs for film and television seem
to i'm disparaging these people but
get it together for christ's sake so
we need a dog trainer trainer
you need to train your dog
trainer training i don't know man
sometimes you see those dogs they like
ring a bell open a door read a book
until you call action yeah until you
call action
then all of a sudden the dumbest [ __ ]
dogs on the planet
i did a thing with a bear once with a
bear where
they just had like a little orange wire
that was supposed to be like an electric
wire they're like so the bear won't go
past this wire and you're like
wait what i think the bear would if it
really wants to it might be like ow that
[ __ ] wire hurt and now i'm really
pissed and i'm just gonna maul everybody
yeah yeah i'm gonna kill everybody
whoever i don't know who's responsible
for that wire so i'm just gonna maul
everyone in sight
okay creeps and listeners it is your
favorite time of the week that's right
the ads oh man and this week guess who
we're brought to you by guess who is
shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big
businesses you know so upstarts startups
and established businesses alike can
sell everywhere synchronize online and
in-person sales and effortlessly stay
informed because success is a million
milestones on a forever evolving path
that's right the american dream reaching
that picture-perfect zenith in life
usually takes a considerable amount of
effort in labor and gain well that's
where shopify comes in it powers
millions of businesses from first sale
to full scale now that sounds like
possibility to me it sounds like success
so guys go to shopify.com
sunny all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
sunny
right now that's shopify.com
[Music]
whoa hold on
where are you going buddy how are you
doing
hey buddy you're not going very fast if
he had those slidy chairs that we have
he could have just he could just slid
right slip right there
we are willing to not force you to write
that review if you are willing to step
up do the right thing and not tell
anybody that this happened i don't care
whatever it takes to get me out of this
bar away from you people my man that is
the attitude we've been waiting that's
right man where's this guy been now we
won't charge you for the duct tape
that was a joke
i really don't like this guy you're an
idiot well we'll see who's the idiot
when he wakes up tomorrow and doesn't
remember a thing i don't think that's
how it works charlie you're not however
oh my god well we may as well embrace
the amnesia angle because we have no
other options at this point okay let's
look get yesterday's newspaper
okay you guys ready
one
two yeah yeah oh yeah
we've already moved
[Music]
[Music]
and it's so
hard to say goodbye
[Music]
i love this episode i enjoyed it very
much yeah i'm going to say that out of
the episodes we've seen so far how many
have we done about 40 something 42. uh
that's in my top ten
really i love that episode i thought
that was great
was it because there was no danny in it
no but i will say i didn't even
notice that not having to
facilitate a
fifth character
we did because we had
corman in there
but i will say that uh it does make it a
little bit easier
to tell more story
um i miss danny in it but i feel like
it's still it's it's one of my it's one
of my favorites it's not one of my
favorites but i don't know i can't
pinpoint why
maybe you're missing danny
yeah maybe that's it yeah something
feels just like a little a little flat
but
i don't know it's not bad i laughed a
lot so yeah and that's what you know
that's the goal right you make something
people laugh at it a lot and uh
that's a goal
and that's a goal
uh how are this feeling so far like
feeling about
[Laughter]
about
um
about the
re-watch like are you guys
you're enjoying this generally speaking
you're
looking back on the old episodes and
thinking like yeah or are you looking
back on the old episodes for the most
part and being like
you know like what's your general feel
it seems like the consensus is
we're enjoying it
i'm enjoying it oh me too absolutely
yeah i mean very proud of the show and
it's nice to go back and feel like the
episodes even the ones that you think
like were misses
aren't as much of a miss as you felt
like they were i'm excited to get to the
ones that i know for a fact that fans
hate that we love oh yeah i think
that'll be fun like like liberty liberty
bell and uh frank's brother yeah yeah
here's a good question because this
whole episode is about like um
criticism and stuff do you guys take any
of that personally when people like do
rankings of the episodes or
criticize the show or any reviews coming
out back then like was this episode was
the idea for this episode to like go
right at criticism in general
i don't take like uh other like people's
um it's more my own criticism right like
if i feel like we're in the editing room
and i feel like ah this one missed the
mark i like i beat myself up man um
that that like hits the hardest you know
because just i you know i want them to
all be great i don't know i'm sure you
guys feel the same but
yeah no absolutely i mean we've touched
on this a little bit but uh i i think if
the
you know if the majority of people like
really dislike something it definitely
bothers me well i'm hoping that um you
guys are driven by it in terms of this
is actually one of the segments i'd like
to add to the show which is who are we
doing at versus which i thought might be
good if every episode we find somebody
for you guys to do the podcast against
um and for this episode i thought we
could do it against negative comments
that we've received about the podcast
which i have in this coffee cup if you
guys wanted to pull any out and read
some negative criticisms
what do you want you want to just grab a
handful of those or no you're going to
take the whole thing out randomly and
then you guys can read some some mean
things that people have said about this
podcast now they have gone to our pages
in order to
um say these things to lodge these
companies so
they want these well they're getting
exactly what they want right now which i
have to say is
there's one reason not to do this but
you know what also [ __ ] everybody so it
could be fun great to see the real tired
and
grumpy actors behind
behind these attractive and polished
characters sure some of the whitest [ __ ]
imma see today
great i mean that's encouraging that's
about right that's pretty white it
doesn't it doesn't get much wider it
doesn't get much when we were doing this
specifically yeah i'm gonna get referred
to that megan this one's anti-you do you
want to hear that great let's see
please give megan uh her own always
sunny podcast so she isn't on this one
so they still want it to be a sunny
podcast just to be clear can you imagine
me running my own sunny podcast
separately from you guys yeah just like
i don't know maybe we should consider it
wow this podcast has gotten so lazy so
fast they pretty quickly went all zoom
even though they said they had a studio
and now glenn just doesn't seem to
doesn't even glenn just doesn't even
bother
soon it will be
uh it will just be megan talking by
herself well to be fair there they were
right there was a period in which we all
had to go and zoom because we were all
working you didn't show up for like two
or three episodes and then we were just
carrying the weight mac out here looking
like a young gilbert godfrey
[Laughter]
i think with the buzz
with the buzzed hair yeah i see it i see
it a little bit i don't see that at all
i see no it's she's right it's the hair
i think it was it's the hair but also
the face a young gilbert godfather
i am a young girl has gilbert got what
was gilbert godfrey ever young
i wonder why all three of their postures
are overly feminine must be something
that naturally happens after living in
hollywood after all those years what the
hell what is that
i think i
like the technology charlie didn't move
at all the two of you just like
wait a second
seriously seriously what are they
referring to
[Laughter]
that's ridiculous
shocked
yeah i don't i don't like understand it
at all
this one makes no [ __ ] sense i don't
like condescending people two episodes
in a row i've had rudeness at the
beginning of it feeling directed towards
me the i'm not your mother i know how to
count dude i love the show lots but
having a woman belittle me at the
beginning of it is not a good feeling
that's because what i put a little
message at the beginning of one of the
podcasts saying um you know we for the
dance episode you should watch this on
youtube because it's really visual and
then i did one to explain why we skipped
mac and charlie die parts one and two
and uh and people thought i was being
condescending no no no no you said
something very funny you said um if you
want this would be a more visual episode
so you should if you a listener could
turn into a creep for an episode so you
should maybe watch it or don't we i
don't care i'm not your mom i'm not your
mom yeah and if somebody doesn't get
that joke they can [ __ ] all the way off
and stop watching all together seriously
dude like seriously man like
shut the [ __ ] up and stop and turn off
your podcast machine
yeah yeah sorry turn off everything and
also how about you uh i love you but i
don't want to be called creeps can we
not do that it's a very sinister word
for people who adore you [ __ ] off turn
it off creep
creep creep creep what a creepy thing
for that creature
[Laughter]
yeah
that leads me to believe that you don't
understand what the television show is
i think it's so funny that this person
doesn't like having a woman belittle
them so they'd be fine if we belittled
them yes they'd love that that's
misogyny well they might have had a
really
shitty mom and it's just bringing up
sure you know this podcast makes me feel
uncomfortable because at some point i've
seen all of their ankles
that's great well come on that's someone
being funny that's it
that's funny i get that i wonder if we
should do a whole episode where we have
no shoes on
really freaked people out well that
would really turn that might actually
spike in the well if me you know what if
meg
did one with no shoes on that would
spike the other oh yeah because you
should you should literally put like
hair on them
and and this guy comes in
and oh you're taking all the photos yeah
this guy comes in to take
photos years ago like starting out did
some play
downtown like uh
and some guy comes in and he's talking
to this actress and it wasn't mary
elizabeth but it was the other woman in
the play
and he said he was like with the l.a
times he's like i'll take some pictures
for the article and he's like you know
what um get comfortable kick your shoes
off and she's like okay and he's taking
pictures
he starts taking pictures of her feet
and she's like what's this she's like no
i'm just i'm getting a variety of things
and then someone like shushes him out of
theaters like yo get out of here and he
like scrambles out he's like i'm so
sorry that guy comes in and takes
pictures pictures of all the actors his
feet
and he always pretends he's like
i was like what an amazing what a life
dude yeah yeah yeah life to just be like
all right okay here comes another show
camera where's my camera what's the film
marty where's the film
he's got an assistant oh he's got he's
got an accomplice
all right all right do i look like a
reporter how do i look all right let's
go go go go but but how nice to know
your thing
so clearly it's like i'm sure this is
what i'm going to do is my whole life's
purpose is get a picture of it and and i
would say there's enough pictures of
people's feet i'm sure on the internet
but uh you know but this guy that's not
enough for him he needs to be it's a
thrill of that i've scammed you yes it's
giving them to me
yes you've shown us otherwise just
hanging out at the beach with a really
long lens camera and you're just
you know you're just [ __ ] scoring all
day baby just [ __ ] feed everybody
you don't need a cover story or anything
you're gonna make your feet all over
this beach you see this [ __ ] oh god but
i didn't talk him into it so okay don't
do nothing for me you know i gotta talk
him in i need to manipulate them into it
work at a shoe store man you know yeah
oh yeah oh my god oh that's overlapping
i do but you guys know i have freakishly
long toes so i i think it's gonna freak
people out
my toe is as long as my pinky finger
no way
like he's measuring no i promise you
it's your nipples are the sizes of dimes
and your and your
your middle toe is i've got this is not
the handwork of the god
i've got toes like fingers man it's
[ __ ] weird yeah how many knuckles can
you open a jar of peanut butter with you
i can't but they barely move they're
like just they're like i don't know
they're like [ __ ] paralyzed
but my feet they don't they they don't
it's it's weird well that brings us to
our final segment which is um did we do
it which is where we discuss whether or
not we did it
i think we did it yeah we did it
felt good i thought we came in hot and
funny
and we ended funny and
[Music]
what more can you want i can come in hot
again either i guys i went to france i
like
oh okay i have all right so so hold on a
second for those who aren't completely
and totally up to speed on this for the
listeners we should pick it up next
episode because buddy you know it's a
whole thing you know in anticipation of
this next episode because i i'm very
much looking forward to this rob
um there was a a time where you came in
hot
about about french people and how um
recognizing that it was ridiculous and
unfair to take an entire country yes and
whittle them down you were being funny
but you were you know disparaging the
french in some ways and uh and then you
had a couple of encounters with some
french people that made you go you know
what
that's just me disparaging an entire
country that's [ __ ] i i've i've just
met a bunch of really great french
people and then you went to france yeah
and i'll leave it at that okay thank you
so we won't no so we're going to find
out
when he went to the country yeah where
these people
are all over the place well it's their
country yeah yeah they're french yes
[Laughter]
final reviews of the table too good like
the table
i'm sure because you changed things up
and you're a woman and you made the the
decision people were yeah
i could use a lumbar pillow
[Music]
you